der ebola ausbruch ist eine mega krise
unsere umwelt wird durch medikamente
vergiftet und das erdbebenrisiko für
deutschland ist höher als bisher bekannt
das sind drei der themen jetzt in die
pixum top five news aus dem clixoom
de/blog höheres erdbebenrisiko in
deutschland auch in deutschland kann es
schwere erdbeben geben das ist das
ergebnis einer ersten übersichtskarte
über die erdbebenrisiken in europa zu
rechnen wissenschaftler in deutschland
jetzt insbesondere im rheingraben und
auf der schwäbischen alb aller 100 bis
150 jahren mit beben mit einer stärke
von bis zu sechs verschiedene regionen
wurden in der studie verglichen und die
ergebnisse übertragen gab es zum
beispiel in einer vergleichbaren region
an einer anderen stelle ein beben wurde
das erdbebenrisiko für ein solches beben
auf die tektonisch entsprechenden
regionen übernommen so wurde
festgestellt dass das erdbebenrisiko in
deutschland höher ist als bisher an
umwelt wird durch medikamente vergiftet
47 prozent der verbraucher entsorgen
ihre abgelaufene medikamente falsch und
vergiften so die umwelt anstatt die
medikamenten reste wie von der
bundesregierung empfohlen über den
restmüll zu entsorgen werden sie in
toiletten oder spülen gekippt so
gelangen wirkstoffe ins abwasser die von
den kläranlagen nicht herausgefiltert
werden können
die folge im grund und damit auch im
trinkwasser sind immer mehr gifte bis
2009 konnten medikamente noch über die
apotheken entsorgt werden mittlerweile
wird empfohlen da für den restmüll zu
benutzen
hier werden die wirkstoffe reste
verbrannt und somit vollständig
unschädlich gemacht weil er wissen dass
zu wenige constanze schromm hatten dazu
auf facebook gepostet die medikamente
die eingenommen werden im körper wirken
und dann raus gepinkelt werden
verseuchten die umwelt auch genau
hinzu kommt nämlich die vergiftung der
umwelt durch die eingenommenen
medikamente durch menschlichen urin und
kot gelangen sie in den natur-
kläranlagen können sie nicht
herausfiltern so dass die wirkstoffe in
den nährstoff kreislauf geraten
ja und der falschen entsorgung soll
jetzt durch eine aufklärungskampagne
über die richtige entsorgung von
medikament
entgegengewirkt geheimnisvolle signale
von dunkler materie empfangen
neue erkenntnisse zur dunkle materie mit
dem chandra teleskop und dem weltraum
observatorium xmm newton der
europäischen weltraumagentur esa hat die
nasa signale empfangen die von sterilen
neutrinos stammen könnten
diese teilchen existierten bisher
lediglich in der theorie jetzt sprechen
die signale aus einem galaxienhaufen im
sternbild des perseus für die existenz
dieser teilchen meinen die
verantwortlichen wissenschaftler dass
diese entdeckung zumindest teilweise die
existenz von dunkler materie erklären
kann
plastikmüll mysteriöses verschwinden in
den weltmeeren
jährlich produziert die menschheit etwa
300 millionen tonnen plastikabfall ein
großer teil davon landet in den
weltmeeren
eine untersuchung hat jetzt ergeben dass
weitaus weniger plastik im wasser
schwimmt als bisher vermutet
des rätsels lösung der großteil des
kunststoffs sinkt in tiefere
wasserschichten ab dann mit der zeit
werden die plastikteile immer weiter
zerkleinert und verteilen sich im wasser
so dass viele tiere sie als nahrung
sehen und aufnehmen so lang dass plastik
in die nahrungskette gefährlich sind
dabei unter anderem die weichmacher die
in plastik enthalten sind mittlerweile
können diese stoffe selbst bei
kleinkindern im blut und im gewebe
nachgewiesen werden außerdem ziehen die
plastik partikel giftige chemikalien an
die ebenfalls von den tieren aufgenommen
werden
die nahrungskette wird somit zunehmend
vergiftet war für langstrumpf dazu auf
facebook wir haben nur die eine erde
unser zuhause
das zerstören die menschen das ist schon
traurig und
ebola ausbruch ist mega krise auf der
konferenz der
weltgesundheitsorganisation whu in der
garage statt accra wurde ein düsteres
bild der ebola epidemie in west afrika
gezeichnet experten rechnen nicht mehr
damit den ausbruch noch dieses jahr
eindämmen zu können
damit ist die solche zu einer epidemie
geworden die jetzt große teile afrikas
bedroht und wohl noch weitere hunderte
tote fordern wird der ebola entdecker
peter pohl bezeichnete die epidemie als
mega krise
er befürchtet einen übergriff der solche
auf marli den senegal und die
elfenbeinküste auf der konferenz wurden
zahlreiche maßnahmen gegen die seuche
beschlossen
es soll enger mit dorfgemeinschaften und
reutlingen zusammen gearbeitet werden um
die bevölkerung besser über die
infektion aufklären zu können
es soll mehr notfallzentren mit mehr
personal geben und es wurde diskutiert
nicht zugelassene medikamente bereits
gegen ebola einzusetzen
die liberianische regierung hat jetzt
per gesetz verboten kranke und tote zu
hause zu verstecken
und unterdessen sind noch mal höhere
opferzahlen der solche genannt worden
laut whu sollen jetzt insgesamt 450
menschen in den betroffenen ländern an
ebola gestorben sein
noch ein hinweis in eigener sache fast
vorwärts eins besuchen
das beste wissenschafts webvideo ein
video wettbewerb vom stifterverband für
die deutsche wissenschaft und
wissenschaft im dialog lage sein video
hoch indem ihr über ein aktuelles
forschungswissen schafft's thema
sprechen es vorstellt oder mit
spannenden experimenten erklärt pro
video gibt es preisgelder bis zu 3000
euro und bis zum einweisen august könnt
ihr eure beiträge einreichen
eine jury in der ich übrigens auch bin
bewertet die videos und gibt den oktober
die besten beiträge zum online voting
frei sucht euch ein thema aus und dem
teil ich bin mir sicher das wird
sensationell den link zur offiziellen
seite findet ihr hier oben rechts
einfach draufklicken oder wie immer alle
links auch in der video beschreibung und
hier oben gehts zum blog wo ist die news
täglich gibt und hier klicken für das
letzte video zum bola solche außer
kontrolle mit aktuellen infos aus
westafrika
wenn ihr dran bleiben möchtet abonniert
den kanal ist er kostenlos
und das war die erste folge von den kick
zum top 5 news wie hat es euch gefallen
ich diskutiere es mit euch wie immer
unten in den kommentaren ansonsten bis
dann bleibt dran